so you're interested in signing up your
child for holiday class with the British
Council I think you're interested to
find out exactly what happens on each
day on the course well let's start with
day one on the first day of course all
the children arrive early in the morning
to meet their teachers for the first
time this is a very important moment in
the day because it's the first time when
they're going to really be introduced to
all of the different staff they'll be
working with them we have young learner
assistance coordinators and of course
the teachers who will teach their
classes the first day is very important
to get the children settled and
comfortable in their new classroom with
their new teachers the teachers will
begin the lessons very much centered on
trying to find out as much information
they can about them to get to know them
but also to assess their level to see if
any of them already have a little
English or not after this the teacher
may introduce for the first time the
story that they're going to be learning
that week the teacher might look at
introducing some new vocab that will be
important to understanding the story
also it's very important that they build
up a portfolio of work that they work on
through the whole week on the first day
they will often design their own covers
for their portfolios and this is a where
they will record all of their work
throughout each of the days day two at
the beginning of the day they usually
will review some of the language that
they learned on the first day
very this is an opportunity to see how
well they've understood and they can
recall some of the key verbs that are
going to be in the story later this can
be done through flashcards they will
teach them some little review games that
they can play together in the class and
again this might be the opportunity on
the second day for them to introduce the
story for the first time the word house
started wealthy this might be an
opportunity for the teacher to actually
show them the story and get them to
interact with the teacher throughout the
story to ask questions and learn more
about the story as they go on again this
is a very important part of the course
to develop their confidence to be able
to move on to using more complex
language later
moving on to day three by this point the
children have already started to take
some of the language on this is a moment
when the teacher might decide finally to
extend the language a little bit further
depending on the age or the level of the
class the teacher will look at more
complex language adjectives maybe verbs
or maybe some grammar structures that
will help them recite some actions and
some of the main events of the story
again if there will usually be
worksheets and some maybe little mini
games which the students will get
involved in and this is an opportunity
really for the teacher to become less
the main focus of the lesson and the
activities become more learner centered
now day four day 4 is already way over
halfway into the course and the children
have really start to develop their
understanding and their confidence to
use English at this point you start to
learn some more longer complex sentences
and phrases that are linked to the story
this is also the day when it becomes
important for the teacher to assign the
roles for the presentations that they're
going to do in the final day this will
be a chance for them to decide who is
going to play which role to enable them
to retell and recite the story for their
parents
another thing that's very important here
is for the teachers to be able to work
with them to improve their pronunciation
there's a lot of longer more complex
language at this point and this is
definitely a chance for the teacher to
work on them to help them in fine tune
their pronunciation to make it sound as
fluent as possible here we are on the
final day of the course of course this
is a day when the children have been
working towards the whole week this is
definitely the chance for the teacher to
really check to knows their roles and
can they really recite the story there
will be several practice sessions with
their teacher and the coordinators will
go through the whole of their story and
the song that they've been learning that
week as well what's very important to
remember at these three things firstly
the whole week takes place in English
from their classes with the English
teacher and also their outdoor games to
their art project but also very
importantly when they're on break times
or at lunch with our young learn
resistance everything takes place in
English secondly very important to know
that young children take time it takes
time for them to internalize all of this
English that they're hearing sometimes
for the first time and it will take time
for some of them to start producing and
develop their confidence to start using
English throughout the week further we
aim to create a positive learning
environment which is engaging for all of
the children from the very young ones to
the older ones this is very important
because this is the basis on which we
can teach them English and enable them
to engage and really have a love for
learning English and get the most out of
this type of course we look forward to
seeing you on the next course opening
very soon
[Music]